es ist nicht nur alt sondern auch mit
keinem anderen lebewesen vergleichbar in
kanada hat eine forscherin jetzt in
einer erdproben einen bisher nicht
bekannten organismus entdeckt fest steht
dass uhr wesen lässt sich keinem unserer
entwicklungs zweige zuordnung
forschungsteams rätseln jetzt ob es sich
um eine art super organismus handelt
alles was er zu dieser sensationellen
entdeckung wissen müsst erfahrt ihr
jetzt bei klick zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich mind blowing
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er kein video herzlich
willkommen
[Musik]
sein name lautet chemie mastix cook
vastic abgeleitet von dem begriff co
qwest und der wiederum steht für einen
oder also unhold der sehr gierig und
haarig ist und aus der mythologie
nordamerikanischer indianer stammt
dieses unwesen das nach ansicht des
kanadischen forschungsteams nicht nur
wie solch ein unhold aussieht sondern
sich auch so benimmt war bisher völlig
unbekannt und unter dem mikroskop sieht
es wirklich ziemlich gruselig aus ein
einzeller der etwa zwei hundertstel
millimeter lang ist und der mithilfe
seiner flagellen vorankommt und dass
eher unkoordiniert als flagellen werden
die kleinen härchen bezeichnet die an
den seiten hervor stehen auf seinem
speiseplan des frisch entdeckten
mikroorganismus stehen kleine mikroben
und die erbeutet er sich ziemlich
geschickt mit seinen extremen damit sind
kleine happen gemeint mit denen er seine
beute beschießt und zu sich heran zieht
um sie dann zu verspeisen und obwohl
diese entdeckung wirklich spektakulär
ist ist es keineswegs so dass nach
diesem mysteriösen wesen lange gesucht
wurde eigentlich war es sogar ein purer
zufall dass der mini organismus entdeckt
werden konnte gepaart mit dem guten
forscher instinkt der kanadischen
evolutionsbiologen jana edith sie hatte
2016 bei einer wanderung in nova scotia
einer ostkanadischen provinz den
richtigen riecher und nahm erdproben mit
als sie diese dann im labor untersuchte
konnte sie ihren augen kaum trauen
seltene unwesen trieben sich in den
proben herum konkret nämlich eukaryoten
protesten
das genannte chaotisch bedeutet dass die
wesen über komplexe zellen verfügen
ebenso wie wir menschen doch die spezies
gehört weder zudem
wilson pflanzen noch tieren dass es mit
dem begriff protest gemeint das neu
entdeckte uhr wesen ist übrigens einzel
ich so wie die meisten protesten jahre
isolierte sie züchteten nahrung für die
mikroorganismen und solange er
irgendwann das unmögliche sie ist
tatsächlich der erste mensch der es
geschafft hat diesen einzeller dann auch
noch zu kultivieren ihn so quasi zu
ihrem haustier zu machen natürlich nur
im übertragenen sinn genetische analysen
standen als erstes mit auf dem plan
damit wollte das forschungsteam
herausfinden wie sich helma sticks kwest
entwickelt hat und mit wem sie verwandt
sind dafür wurde eine äußerst neue und
innovative technik genutzt der name
single cell transkripte nomics mit
dieser methode können genetische
informationen sequenziert werden und die
technik ist sogar bei zellen möglich die
firma kleiner sind als ein einzelner
menschliche haarstrang das besondere
hierbei ist dass man die gewünschten
infos aus zwei oder vier zellen erhalten
kann
anstatt wie bei standards verfahren
millionen von zellen zu benötigen und
mit diesem ergebnis hatte wirklich
niemand gerechnet dass uhr wesen lässt
sich tatsächlich keinem unserer
entwicklungs zweige zu ordnen ist
simpson einer der beteiligten forscher
der kanadischen dalhousie university
sagt diese entdeckung lässt uns den baum
des lebens quasi neu zeichnen und zwar
an seiner tiefsten stelle außerdem
eröffnet uns die entdeckung die
möglichkeit die evolution und den
ursprung komplexer zellen neu zu
verstehen und zwar lange bevor überhaupt
tiere und pflanzen auf der erde gab das
forschungsziel geht jetzt davon aus dass
sich ein gemeinsamer vorfahr weit zurück
in der vergangenheit finden lässt also
vor etwa einer milliarde jahren also
unglaubliche 500 millionen jahre bevor
sich die ersten tiere entwickelten
doch klar ist dass bisher noch nicht
also zunächst soll jetzt erst einmal das
komplette genom sequenziert werden dazu
heißt es in der studie
dass es eine ganz neue möglichkeit um
die entwicklung von komplexen zellen und
deren ursprünge zu erforschen
das forschungsteam jedenfalls ist immer
noch fassungslos über seinen eigenen
erfolg dazu sitzen darf sich solch eine
lebensform buchstäblich unter unseren
füßen verstecken können macht uns
deutlich wie wenig wir noch
die vielfalt des lebens auf der erde
wissen da denken wir nur im weltraum
können wir wirklich neues bahnbrechendes
entdecken dabei kann es sich auch direkt
unter unseren füßen befinden wenn ihr
absolut nichts von klicks
umsatzzuwächsen verpassen wollt dann
abonnieren auch den englischen kanal
denn nur dann verpasst ja auch keine
videopremieren denn die gibt es genauso
dort dafür einfach hier klicken und
weiter geht's mit frankenstein erst wie
serge create human red wings ich freue
mich auf euch auch auf dem englischen
kanal zu tun
stay tuned